thank you
hi guys I've got a video request about
leadership from you guys
and so I thought about this and I want
you to know that if you want to be an
okay leader then well that's easy but if
you want to become a great leader there
are five important things that you must
understand
number one
leadership is more about other people
you need to understand that he's got
almost nothing to do with you but
everything to do with those you lead Lau
2 said a leader is best when people
barely know he exists when his work is
done he's aim fulfilled they will say we
did it ourselves
you see being a great leader is not
about making a big name for yourself it
is about empowering others to become
great you will never be a great leader
if you want to do everything yourself or
take all the credit and if you do you
need to know that that is usually also
the difference between
a leader who just leads with instruction
and a leader who leads with inspiration
serve others
leadership is about serving other people
because that causes inspiration it
inspires them it makes them want to be
better it makes them want to follow you
invest in them invest in people not in
things or certain programs invest in
people
you know one of the best leaders of all
time in my book he is the best leader of
all time
Jesus he said this
but Jesus called them to himself and
said you know that the rulers of the
Gentiles domineer over them and those in
high position exercise authority over
them it is not this way among you but
whoever wants to become prominent among
you shall be your servant and whoever
desires to be first among you shall be
your slave just as the son of man did
not come to be served but too sir and to
give his life as a ransom for many now
think about this powerful statement some
of you might agree and some of you might
not agree you might be thinking at this
moment oh come on this is so stupid this
is so silly if I'm the leader I'm not
going to serve other people they should
serve me
if this is the way that you're thinking
then you are part of the problem that's
in this world let's take a look at
political leaders your government
they're supposed to serve the people and
make life easier for them but now most
of them are selfish and corrupt and they
have the same attitude as you I don't
want to serve other people they should
serve me
yes and how good is that logic working
out in the world name one government
that is really good serving the people
the way they should
if there was one the people would follow
them and serve them back out of love not
out of fear or control
but out of love because if you serve
when you lead it inspires
lead by example
look guys everything that you do shows
your leadership skills and people will
look here
what you say but they will mostly look
at what you do
you truly want to be a great leader then
you need to ask yourself this question
would you follow you
now
if you've thought about a little bit and
you said quickly well of course I will
think about it again when I ask you
these questions are you always honest
are you always reliable
do you always complete a goal that you
have set
do you always act within the three C's
of leadership Clarity consideration and
courage
do you act with humility
do you show transparency
are you patient with people
do you truly care about other people
do you have integrity doing the right
thing even when no one is looking
do you have the confidence to stand up
for good values and morals even when
people are against you these are only
some of the qualities that a great
leader has
do you think you're a great leader
well if you already are a leader if you
have a leadership position at work at
school or wherever you are
earn it
every single day
live the way you preach
do what you say you will do you cannot
just say things and not commit to it you
see that with politicians all the time
they make all these promises before
elections and then when the time comes
they do nothing
how does that make you feel
yeah not great right
so how do you think other people feel
when you lead them and you don't do what
you said you will do
live the way you preach
because if you do people will follow you
voluntarily
there's a quote that says become the
kind of leader that people would follow
voluntarily even if you had no title or
position you know a lot of people just
want to be a great leader because it's
about them they're so selfish oh I will
be great
leadership is not about the best title
or the person who has the most followers
you need to understand this a great
leader is the one who creates the most
leaders
good leaders who understands that it is
about relationships
take responsibility
weak leaders flee when times are tough
but it is when the strong leaders rise
up and you can see it clearly because
when times are tough these men
stand strong for what they believe in
and they lead the way with boldness with
courage and with a lot of confidence
this requires the three R's respect for
yourself respect for others and
responsibility for your and their
actions
if you lead then you are responsible for
the direction and the outcome of every
day
even if it's other people who's doing
things because if they acted out of your
leadership
then the result is also your
responsibility and if things go wrong
don't blame them but own it like a man
like a great leader
fix it and even when you fix it don't go
back and say all right I had to come and
fix this now trying to look better than
they are because then you're still
giving the blame to them then you are
like a real boss Russell hewing said a
bus fixes blame a leader corrects
mistakes a boss creates fear a leader
confidence a boss knows all a leader
asks questions a boss makes drudgery a
leader makes it interesting a boss is
interested in himself a leader is
interested in the group now go and
become a great leader become a man of
value that is changing this world for
the better if you want to know more
check out this video here and I'll see
you there and before you go always
remember this life is short so don't
waste yours cheers guys